Shen's is you want to factor the
numerator in factor the denominator
that's the first step so what I would do
is I would go ahead and factor this so
we get X minus 3 times X plus 2 over X
plus 2 times X minus 1 okay so you can
see this is 2x and negative 1x it adds
up to the middle term 1x you can foil it
make sure you factored it correctly but
what you'll notice is that X plus 2
factor cancels in the numerator
denominator now normally we you know we
don't want the denominator equal to 0
because that's undefined and we would
get a vertical asymptote normally but
when the factor in the numerator and
denominator cancel like this you don't
get a vertical asymptote you actually
get a removable discontinuity it's
actually like a hole in the graph now if
you graph it on your graphing calculator
you might not see that hole because it's
infinitely small it's just like a little
pixel right so what we're gonna do this
graph is actually going to behave like y
equals x minus 3 divided by X minus 1
except for there's gonna have that
little hole in the graph now how do you
locate where the hole is well you can
see that negative 2 is going to make
this equal to 0 or undefined if you take
negative 2 and put it into what's left
over
okay after you cancel those factors out
you get negative 2 minus 3 over negative
2 minus 1 which is negative 5 over
negative 3 which is a positive 5/3 so
the location of our holes in negative 2
5/3 which is like 1 in 2/3 it's about
right there okay see if I can make a
little bit more accurate right about
there okay now the next thing we're just
going to proceed and graph this entire
rational function you're gonna want to
look at the highest degree term in the
numerator which is x squared and the
highest degree term in the denominator
now as X gets larger and larger these
terms are more influential on the
equation then these terms are so we can
cover those up temporarily and just
realize that the graphs going to behave
as X is really large like x squared over
x squared because they're growing at the
same rate we look at the ratio of the
coefficients that's 1 over 1 so y equals
1 it's going to be our horizontal
asymptote so there we go there's our
horizontal asymptote like so okay so
then the next thing is we're going to
look at the vertical asymptotes and we
know that we can't divide by zero so
that means X can
equal one we're having a vertical
asymptote at x equals one which is right
here so I'm going to draw that and it's
just a dotted invisible Y like so now
the next thing is we're going to analyze
the X intercepts and y intercepts so I
like just to make a little table like
this set X to 0 to find the y intercept
set why does your o to find the x
intercept keep it simple right so you
put 0 in for X you can see these terms
are going to cancel out and we get
negative 6 over negative 2 which is
positive 3 so the y intercept here is
going to be 1 2 3 right there okay and
if we set Y to 0 okay now follow me on
this one so nice students get confused
by this if you set Y to 0 the only way
that Y will be 0 is if the numerator is
0 because if the numerator is 0 in the
denominator is not 0 that fraction is
equal to 0 so by setting the top to 0
you can see that x equals 3 is going to
be our x intercept so that's 1 2 3 all
right now it looks like the graphs
coming together the only thing I would
do now is maybe take a look at a few
points as you approach the vertical
asymptote from the left and from the
right so what we can do is we can do is
what's called sign analysis I'm going to
pick a point like point 9 just a little
shy of x equals 1 if I put point 9 into
this factored form here point 9 minus 3
gives us a negative and point 9 minus 1
gives us a negative and a negative
divided by a negative is a positive so
that tells us this graphs going up
towards positive infinity which you
could probably tell already from these
points that we have right here but just
to show you a little bit more and then
over here let's see when you approach
the vertical asymptote from the right
side let's say we put in one point one
that's going to give you one point one
minus three is a negative one point one
minus one is a positive a negative
divided by positive is a negative which
tells you as you're approaching this
vertical asymptotes the graphs going
down down down so basically the graphs
gonna look something like that